okay let's go next to our caller from
the 614 area code who is
finding themselves on the line today
from six one four
hi david uh this is uh from uh
powell ohio ulaschini okay i'm realizing
when you send super chats i've been
mispronouncing your name but i
appreciate that now
no it's okay i can't yeah that's cool
that you remember that
um but um i just have a i have a
question um
for like the longer but the long run of
the progressive party so i i recently
saw a clip
from the kyle kalinski show where he
talks about
um you know he gave his input that if
the left and progressives want to enact
um progressive policies um they would
have to take over
the the democratic party because we're
obviously in a two-party system
and i was just wondering what your what
your view was on that like do you think
that an
overrunning of the of the democratic
party is the way to go
or do you think a third party is an
option so that you know the lesser of
two evils argument doesn't really
exist anymore so i was just wondering
what you thought about that listen you
really have to work both angles at the
same time
obviously in an ideal system we wouldn't
have a two-party system where if you're
not a democrat or a republican at least
at everything other than a local level
you essentially have no power even the
few independents in the senate caucus
with the democrats in this case it's
bernie and angus king so
i would be working to try to change
campaign finance and how elections are
structured which are really the two big
issues that we need to change if a third
party is ever going to have a shot but
simultaneously if you only do that
and you don't infiltrate the democratic
party at all
you could lose 5 10 20 100 years i mean
who knows how long that first process is
going to take so you need to be doing
both you've got to be able to walk and
chew gum at the same time
right yeah yeah absolutely i mean i just
uh i always thought that the answer was
somewhere in the middle and you don't
have to kind of
go to one side or the other so yeah i
appreciate that thank you so much david
thanks for everything you do
all right thank you for the call great
to hear from you